hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and I'm John and I'm Andrew Andrew nice
tone I like it boom Andrew from the
movie source channel is here with us
today this man loves a good Star Wars
movie he loves movies in general so why
don't you go follow this guy who passed
20 150 followers and Stardust hell yeah
thank you guys for following us on that
half down the link of follow us first is
this sir chance right now to say that
Stardust was used in a Star Wars film
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna do a spoiler
talk today you know there's all spoilers
so if you get mad at us in the comments
you're an idiot if you haven't seen Star
Wars and you're watching this video to
just spread the spoilers around that
sucks that sucks that is a bad thing to
do I also know I can't do anything about
it
so guys I figure we start small Luke
dies at the end of this honestly from
the very beginning I had a feeling I was
gonna love this movie when the opening
sequence started the humor bid that I
feel like a lot of people have been
touching on is specifically with general
Hux and Poe in the beginning of this
film
general Hux is giving like typical
villain speech tojust is acting like hey
can I speak to Hawks please it was
hilarious
it was really funny it was a little bit
like whoa this could be that movie it's
gonna be a funny movie it also really
reminded me of the beginning of the
force awakens when kylo Ren is up close
with Poe and he's like so who talks
first do I talk first to you first
yeah okay I just like set the tone again
with that humoristic side and I also
looked at not just from a humoristic
perspective I looked at it as an
intellectual perspective like he was
stalling him like it's it was an
interesting plan smart planning I love
how at the end works yeah I love how at
the end the commander whoever says to
general X are you're being played like
it's like it's like it's a good
satisfying payoff and to see general X's
face like when he knows you got played
like it were yeah and while it is a
self-aware joke it still comes from the
character of Poe we know him they have
something of a sense of humor in these
situations
cuz I've heard people say that they felt
some of the humor was off in this movie
and I really didn't feel that and I feel
like I'm kind of explaining that one
opening sequence says a lot about this
stuff you find the humor to be off I
can't think it was specific moment I was
like this is all I didn't
it was forced I just felt it was organic
[Music]
George no pun intended I didn't feel
like it was forced I felt like it was
very organic in this film in I'll
definitely say this there is a lot more
humor in this than most Star Wars films
for sure and that's gonna take some
people again used to because they're not
used to seeing humor of this level but
on the other side it does work in the
context of the film if I'd actually
funny yeah and it's very organic I can
see what people are on about with this
one that was a thing about the first
part of this movie that took me some
getting used to in that and the thing is
I laughed at all the jokes it's that
kind of laughs where you furrow your
brow cuz you're like I'm surprised this
is this is here but after the scenes
played out and I got used to the tone I
do look back having enjoyed the humor
but I can definitely see why some people
are not about it I think when you adjust
to it you realize that it's fine I feel
like on a second viewing I don't feel
like any time I felt off would feel like
it's not off on a second view because I
love the moment - Luke gets the
lightsaber it cuts the loop of the
lightsaber because all that buildup
what's one again that's another one of
those jokes that is of the character so
I can't really fault the movie yeah yeah
like it is totally unexpected hilarious
yeah and there was one two words like
the fight later with him in Kyllo where
he's using the force to project himself
and again that's not even he's not even
saying anything he's just he's just
taunting him because he knows that he's
gonna he's gonna like go yeah yeah the
interactions between him and Chewie and
then him an r2 like that was a cheap
shot you know those are good again
organic humoristic moments I kind of
feel like this movies with its humor
segue to way into learning more about
what the force really is all about from
an emotional aspect because I was
thinking about that scene when you're
gonna reach out and she literally
reaches out well I think about the force
awakens where Han that's for starters
yeah I feel like this movie as compared
to previous Star Wars movies has a broad
tone
is somewhat heavier at certain points
more kind of heart-wrenching that I'm
used to in some of the past and so
there's maybe not from from the
originals as much but they they rang
true here well the reason I want to talk
about the beginning though it's that
opening battle sequence I was already
seeing so that this could possibly be
the best-looking Star Wars movie that if
the movie doesn't play out great by the
scene is done this is gonna be one of
the best-looking Star Wars movies
because there are some I feel like a lot
of times in the battle sequences in
these movies it's easy to kind of just
remember it all as a blur when I watch
this movie though I can remember like
specific shots with roses sister when
she's trying to get rid of the bombs
that whole sequence 10th see how I was
it was vested in this woman I don't know
that maybe yeah here oh yeah it was
heartbreaking and you didn't know
exactly where the half of the medallion
was and then that connection to the
other sister was a brute I thought that
was brilliant because who the hell was
expecting to find this storyline that
was so touching and they felt and dad
you on that scene you were just talking
about with roses sister the way like you
think it's dropped into space and that
she catches it away the camera were like
it's it was really a dance and a lot of
tension-filled moments in that specific
scene so yeah I appreciate that too
about characters you don't really know a
lot about you're still feeling that that
investment attention like you don't want
something you know harmful wrap in them
so I appreciated that as well people
love to touch on rogue one as being a
war movie yeah but this movie really did
feel like both in its handling of the
action and its use of it in the plot it
always felt like the stakes were huge
and they orchestrated those battle
sequences really well to the point where
maybe the most lucidly during a Star
Wars experience I've sat there and gone
yeah
Star Wars yeah I feel that you know
especially those dogfights out in space
the beginning one the stuff with the
escape pods later that is all one area
and it evolves you know they jump once
in hyperspace but for all intents and
purposes that's one battle of this war
and you watch it unfold and there are
different kinds of fights inside of that
I remember one of the most visually
impressive shots
I've seen in any Star Wars movie when
Laura Dern's character vice-admiral ball
horde or at
she sacrificed herself in a tree here
with that name let's see what she does
sacrifice herself which by the way I
thought was great because when the
Loranger was first in this movie I was
like oh you just showed it to be like
the [ __ ] character that wouldn't lay
awakes
up and she has that whole relationship
established with labor like oh actually
like each other they're not like me or
something and then when Lauren
sacrifices herself makes the jump to
hyperspace that shot with the sound
design and the different cuts they use
and the way was the not sound yeah that
was that was ripped at homeand because
for the first time it's just nothing
yeah that sequence is one of the most
striking visual sequences like I was
caught up in that like that's one of the
most memorable movie moments of the year
for me yeah we were in a press screaming
and the whole entire audience gasps
every moment whoa yeah it was definitely
was visually very appealing but I think
like what I obviously the visual is what
I appreciated the most but I also
appreciate from a story perspective like
her sacrifice like what she was doing in
the moment like it was very well earned
in like it was like the emotional
feeling that you get towards her
character making a sacrifice like it
really like it really paid off in that
moment on top of the incredible visuals
that we got in that yeah in that moment
it's just really blending together hold
oh is it like a new character you get to
experience from the outside and I love
that the movie sort of lets you sit
there for the first part and go oh I
think this person very much by the end
of it you're like ah
I see you like you're fully enveloped
poised you're not something they didn't
have some twist where she's like corrupt
or something yeah and we're really
working with the first order yeah and it
gives you reasons to doubt her you know
her time and you make these decisions
with Paulo out of the time and I and I
like that the movie doesn't ever it
gives you the credit just lets you
believe for a little bit and then it
unfolds I don't read the comics or know
a lot about the EU very much but I do
know that her character hold o her and
Leia were actually childhood friends
pick up on that kind of friendship and
the way their performance so I don't but
they gave you hints of that it's all
with him the performances of those two
actresses right then and there I feel
like the way you're really going to
swirl about this is talking about the
characters journeys in this film which
is a good thing does a great thing makes
a job why yeah I think
me I like to pose personally that was
your favorite story I was one of my
favorites like just his arc in terms of
saving his wife and daughter from the
Empire no like in the beginning of this
film all he wants to do it's he kind of
he just wants to fight through
everything wants to you know he's all
about destroying in order to achieve
victory and it's an understandable trade
for someone who's the greatest pilot in
the galaxy I like you know through Leia
slaps and on all the speed in the morale
speeches he gets like he sees throughout
the film no maybe I'm not taking the
proper approach to this and so I liked
how his character matured and his arc
that he went through and at the
progression that his character went
through I thought it was very well
earned and I just appreciated where they
took the character towards the end of
the film Leia I really see the change in
this character and it's like like this I
like where they took this character from
the beginning the film to the end of the
film from the beginning of the force
awakens to where we are now and I really
also appreciated how they used this
character a lot more smarter in this
film than in the previous video yeah I
felt like Leia story coincided a lot
with post Pacific saury ok she's his
example of leadership like real
leadership and that you know she raises
that theme beyond that what I thought
was really fascinating was this whole
time we've been kind of setting up oh
like he's the new Han Solo in some way
Leia back then you know falls in love
with Han Solo she with young Leia would
have fallen in love with with a poet I'm
a guy and now this time around she's
really grown up and she's really mature
now she's sort of mentoring the younger
Han Solo who gets these like life
lessons about being the hotshot hothead
ain't exactly always the best thing to
do it exactly always the coolest thing
to do you know and I like that this
movie of all movies chose to to take up
that kind of a storyline because you
know in a day and age where Chris Pratt
plays Han Solo in like three different
like it's nice to watch a movie like
this that is responsible for creating so
much of our blockbuster cinema sit down
and go you know we can't always do Han
Solo because that doesn't actually
always help us win over yeah yeah you
made a great point I love what you just
said about how she's mentoring him and
her husband was exactly the type of
character he is but I think one little
baby grape I had that I would have liked
I mean didn't really matter was
in the world but she took away his
status it was captain a commander or
whatever he was yeah she demoted him but
I would I think I would have liked just
again me personally just a little payoff
at the end where at the end where he's
finally like you know kind of accepted
more of this mature way of thinking in
terms of in battle you get that pav
versing command like giving him the the
reprieve back to the promotion of back
where he was you see that the character
is like finally you've learned so yeah
it just would have appreciated like that
little moment pay off there I don't know
I felt like by the time they got to the
end of this movie they didn't really
care about slow it's gonna say you're
right I just mean that character moment
that like of Leia saying you've matured
I'm so proud of where you've come from
what we've talked about earlier to where
you've come now like it'll be in a
Warner Brothers extended cut of this
movie yeah
but speaking of lay-up really loved the
way she was handled in this film
I love the resemblance she just had to
how Carrie Fisher actually is and try
making her dialogue sound like how young
Leia talk you sound like how Carrie
Fisher sounds when I hear hear me you
know just have a lot less vulgar you
know but she's still got that like she
seems like she's been around
yeah and that's and that carries over to
Luke 2 like it's cool that they let them
age not only physically obviously but in
personality well well I think why it
works is because at this point Leia
should be a character where he just seen
her I she's a woman of experience and
Carrie Fisher has that same demeanor or
had that same demeanor of just she's a
woman who's lived that has annexed
experiences so just translating that
where it's perfectly for who general
Leia is there was one moment though that
I just can't seem to figure out I
haven't even looked it up can't figure
it out yeah when when she died because
my feeling I thought she diodes and then
is freezing out in the vacuum of space
well how do you feel Andrew when you
thought she does I didn't like that when
I thought she does I personally thought
it happened too soon yeah and if in the
moment and then we like first that I
mean I was very happy yeah I was very
happy that she survived I still don't
know how I feel about the whole force
like again visually it was really it was
very interesting to see a different
perspective of someone using the force
in a different way yeah you know cuz we
don't always have to do the same exact
thing
it's really cool to see other different
abilities that you can do while using
the force and from that perspective it
was interesting but I still don't know
how I feel you know I don't want to be
negative but I don't know how I feel yet
about how she force food and then came
back to life maybe if you're a hardcore
intense Star Wars fan you'll get it I
feel like I'm encountering a lot of
people who are like I honestly don't get
what happened yeah that's one of the
things that actually took me out of the
movie because I didn't actually hate the
moments leading up to that that whole
strange moment between her and kylo and
now I guess in in in retrospect seeing
the way they use other aspects of the
force later on in the movie maybe they
were like legit seeing each other or
something like that but that that moment
kind of caught me up and I was thinking
this is a big movie with lots of moving
parts lots of characters if this is the
time maybe this is it they're spending a
lot of time looking at her so the idea
of her death didn't bug me and then when
she woke up I was kind of like huh and
then she floats back and it actually
took me out of the stake so I was like
oh cool
lei is safe whatever that to me I
thought I didn't it didn't have the
triumph that I they clearly wanted it
just felt like a deus ex machina to me I
was part of the crowd and III felt it
too after a while went on and I realized
this movies never gonna explain what the
hell went on then I was like questioning
it but in that in the moment when it
happened I was actually like oh sweet
lei is awesome you know I guess I missed
out on the awesome part I got the relief
of like oh good she's still alive
because I want to keep on watching her
but you know in a couple movies that now
are taking time to dissect the force a
bit you know movie following up that's
not how the force works that's one
example in this movie where I'm like how
does the force work yeah does this
possible and I'm sure somebody can I was
gonna say like does that mean Luke and
the Empire Strikes Back when he was
gonna fall you know in the Cloud City
could've just used his like the force
like that I don't know well and I mean
you're in the vacuum of space
yeah I'm pulling you're probably also
propelling I'd still like in the moment
like I was cheering too because finally
we get to see Leia using the force from
that perspective and in the moment it
was really cool and visually it was
really appealing to see but they didn't
really make an explanation I think that
would have helped use me a little bit
more and again I getting too negative
but I would have appreciated just again
just some kind of an explanation just
what exactly happened it was nice to see
that she survived obviously like I was
happy about that obviously it wasn't the
death that was gonna bother me it was
just where it happened in the film like
that because we were still pretty early
on the film at that point so I did think
she was gonna die in the film I just
didn't think we would have happened that
early in terms of her dying and that way
even not just the time but just in that
way would have upset me a trailers
pretty much gave that away because I
know kylo doesn't shoot her which was
awesome on kylos part but it's like okay
with the people you have wine with good
moments yeah yeah and the other part
about it is I would have felt like oh
man there was so much I wanted to see of
it because they really utilized Han a
lot in force awakens but I was really
excited to see Carrie Fisher - but she's
barely in it so I was like I would hate
it she's barely in the movie so that's
it sort of the time part and the other
part is like well she just died there
I've been like well that sucks because
she never got a scene with Luke and it
really bothered me that Han and Luke
didn't get a scene together friend and
now I'm like no it's great now Carrie
Carrie Fisher Mark Hamill exactly that
is a great point I still wish we could
have gotten all three of them together
in one scene but even even when he's
using the force he's brother yeah
oh and that scene with Leia and Luke
Luke's story that was so rewarding cuz
they have all the stories they had to
nail it was this story they had today
and I think the film also clearly shows
that Rian Johnson's most personal
investment was in the end uh kylo and
Rey and ray and Luke story yeah like you
could tell that's where his main
passion of this story was act as it all
circles around that story
oh yeah well and it's magical to see
solution Alton
Luke Skywalker it feels like a different
Star Wars movie and yet were we've got
Luke back yet
for real the Holden Matt like master and
pupil dynamic that he sets up with Rey
is awesome because it's it's a typical
like that's reminiscent in ways of like
Luke training with Master Yoda and all
that but the whole crux of it is he
doesn't want to do it and it's all about
him trying to convince her not to they
kind of try and it doesn't go so well
and he also has to face his trauma like
Luke has is such a big character growth
in here because he's traumatized he's
lost his faith he doesn't even practice
using the force he lives in isolation
protecting old books I mean the trailers
I guess in a sense do you kind of ruin
that impact because while people
theorize Luke might be a little bit like
that in the last Jedi when you're
watching the force awakens and even when
you get to Luke you're not think you
know he's a grumpy old guy who's given
up on the force and like they doesn't
want to train Rey and all that stuff
it's like you're more like what is he
doing there you know that's why that
moment where he just throws the
lightsaber
oh he just doesn't want to do this yeah
and I like the lifestyle he was living I
like how they took time to show here's
how he's been surviving on this island
co drinking you know drinking the blue
milk nectaries shows such as Mark Hamill
is a funny guy so I like that they
allowed me to do the mixture of humor
with a darker interpretation of Luke
Skywalker yeah well and and at this
point in their life after it's funny to
watch new heroes rise while older heroes
are still around and the the more I
think about that the more that makes
sense yeah by this point Luke would have
a bit of an attitude I'm sure I know
this version of Luke Skywalker isn't the
Luke Skywalker we all remembered growing
up however in terms of performance old
man Luke is Mark Hamill's best yeah in
terms of performs his Logan man this is
located F initely an interesting choice
where they took the character from where
we had previously seen him in
the Jedi to where we have now seen them
so it's a bold choice I always say
ballsy is the word I was looking for the
bold is a good one too yeah I really
think there's gonna be a lot of people
who are divisive on how they feel about
where they took Lou because he's
definitely not the same like the era
we've left off and returned the Jedi
it's not like hey he's going off on
kick-ass adventures he's gonna go fight
snow he's gonna go with Ray's gonna go
fight with kylo don't expect that like
that's not exactly what's happening here
and you know we go more into a personal
traumatized story with obviously you
mentioned he's not you know handling
dealing with the fame or with the force
anymore he doesn't believe in is in his
religion anymore any of em he's lost
whole faith but I thought they took an
interesting approach where you know when
they showed the flashbacks of how he
lost Ben where he started seeing moments
of darkness and him and I'm surprised
that like they it was interesting that
you know the character when he saw that
his father had turned to the dark side
he tried talking him down and turning
him to the light and I found it
interesting that they didn't use that
with Luke where he maybe tries to
talking you know Ben but I did
appreciate the moment where he's like he
felt wrong and what he was doing he let
fear take over instead that's that's
like a path to the dark side I really
did theorize that they were gonna go
more the great Jedi route and this is
the great Jedi basically it's where you
Teeter on the edge of dark on the dark
side but you're still you know you still
maintain that edge and you you don't
fully embrace the dark side but you you
know you have light and dark yeah you
know inside of you I'm surprised I
didn't go that route but there were
definitely some you know interesting
choices made and ballsy choices made
well the fact that they let his
character grow into an arc that I'm sure
we all saw coming because even when like
all hope seems lost in the finale I
think I looked over at John and I'm like
I wanted that the way he shows up is
symmetrical for a bunch of different
reasons and that's one of those
mumbo-jumbo we're moments of the force
that I thought actually did work is like
projects himself out there that's how
powerful he is with the force yeah and
and and you know home lightsaber fight
yeah and that whole fight is like how
they handle that fight like a samurai
battle yeah it was like an actual
samurai battle also too I like the the
moment the hints that they were giving
you that Luke wasn't actually there
first of all his haircut I was thinking
yeah you'd like he dyed his hair color
hey I gotta go fight Kyle oh I need a
haircut right now so like a top top
versus a reshoot yeah Elsa - I did
notice you know on the planet creep
whenever you make a step I love the
shots that Ryan Johnson's cream whenever
you take a step you see the red the red
the red mineral salt so that was really
awesome visual storytelling with how
that plan at work when Luke was walking
I didn't notice any of the footprints
that he was for him like like it was he
was giving you hints there you just had
to really pay attention to it both
finale had a great blend of proper
fanservice serving the plot because that
was like Luke showing up to save the day
we all wanted that and that's what we
get we talk about the theories all the
time pretty sure this is obvious that
Mark Hamill is gonna come back as a
force ghost or Luke Skywalker but it
kind of did not really I kind of hope
you do you think that do you think folk
cool handle it if you since that line
though where he says to you around kid
do you think that was maybe a
foreshadowing of him as a force ghost
with kylo Ren or do you think just him
in general see you around well he said
something to him beforehand right if you
strike me down in anger I will almost
stay I'll stay with you forever yeah
something like that yeah that's nice I
see you around kid
yeah I'm in your head now yeah whether
you like it or not
you got to live with you and to do that
moment where everyone's firing in and
then he just walks off and I like to
general huh we did haven't really talked
about general where he's like he's like
do you think you got him again this bill
adds more than home you're high low
knows we didn't get oh yeah I like that
they finally gave Huck's like a joke cuz
he's too [ __ ] most like that seems to
be the point I don't know I like how
they wrote that character just have a
lot of comic relief because I'm I would
prefer this version of general Hux
over the whatever version of general Oh
totally unfortunately I'm like yeah yeah
he was more into big speeches in that
and not that he was a good especially in
that movie to what has to ask you know
like Oscar Iser was a supporting
character of ex machina da Mona Lisa was
the lead in terms of male and now it's
very evident that Oscar Isaac has a much
bigger role in this franchise that
they're both starring in together do you
think they have tension they don't even
have scenes together I mean they had a
scene together but they're not over over
the speaker yeah oh man just like an x
mark and now he's being played a [ __ ]
you know I'm not a big fan when the
studio's make the idea to like pass the
baton and I think the franchise is
handling that super well in terms of
like you get hot in there he interacts
with Rey and Finn a lot and in this
movie with Luke and Leia's presence in
this film we all got excited for were
force awakens was to see the old stars
return you know it's not about that
anymore I'm like Nanak's that Rey and
Luke's it's a rage story it's kinda
Ren's story you know like these stories
I'm also excited to keep on going with
now the scenes with Luke and kylo when
they're going back to the past I like
how that was handled
I was also intertwining how her
relationship with kylo was forming well
yeah this movie does a it's smart that
they let arguments and information
trickle out and go back and forth you
know and and the truth about Luke and
kylos history is a great example of that
because first you have you know one idea
about like ah kyla was just out of
control and then you have like the uh
Luke really did something horrible and
then you have the grey and then it
bothers to go to all three places great
Jedi right there cuz I like that more
like oh he did what bad his lightsaber
but he chose in that moment not like he
was realizing like what am i doing yeah
it wasn't just oh he was gonna do it
it's what else was there to that yeah
why wouldn't we just trigger kylo to the
end them that story with kylo and Ray
that was really good oh man now I wasn't
expecting this part of the story to be
arguably the more the most intriguing
part to me perhaps actually but the most
enjoyable part of the most intriguing
part because when they're first talking
to each other when they first see each
other I love the way that was built up
and I love how this movie does explore
the grey in like every area it's more
than just kylo might be a good
it's way more than that fellow they
embrace through Kyllo most of all they
embrace chaos they say like there's
there's chaos within him right now like
there is debate yeah
and that conflict conv really say that
word and I love the way they
orchestrated their scenes together yeah
visually at least nope did he say at
some point that he's the one yeah yeah I
like that that's that's a nitpick that
did kind of subtract a little bit but
but overall I love the way those scenes
were orchestrated you're understanding
why Ray is even siding with Kailah and I
love how this movie deals with that plot
by the time you get to the scene where
Ray is held captive and she's in front
of smoke and smokes like beating the
[ __ ] out of her or while he's also like
destroying the rebellious haeseong
invited me so much to Return of the Jedi
yeah and it was interesting because
they're like oh you're getting like The
Return of the Jedi homage here in the
second one so they're not doing the this
exact structure and that's why I love
the idea of how they keep going familiar
now we're gonna flip it familiar now
we're gonna change it you know and that
aspect in and of itself almost made me
feel better about the force awakens
because I started to wonder if maybe the
part of the arc of this trilogy is to go
okay let's remind you about where we
came from and do a similar story to that
and now this one's all about how not all
of that stuff's gonna work in here yeah
all the old ways are relevant anymore we
don't new approaches because like we had
a tribe that's actually really thought I
would I agree with that and I would also
say they heard some of the complaints on
it's a rehash of the New Hope's
overnight I felt like that was super
intentional this is the force awakens
and I feel like it's even more present
because this doesn't feel like jarring
tonal shift or jarring what the hell's
going on with the story it feels like oh
this is smooth you know yeah and then it
makes it feel like okay the third parts
probably gonna be even more different
yeah hope I don't be an ending to this
or yeah it's JJ Abrams so we might get
an exact copy for sure
just on an alternate timeline learner
like two of the characters back to that
scene though it's like you knew kylo is
gonna do something to help out right
yeah you knew that but I don't think we
any of us really
oh [ __ ] I was gonna kill [ __ ] if you
really watch you saw the the lightsaber
was starting to turn yeah you mean
before that before that I wasn't
expecting him to actually like I didn't
I don't know who's gonna catch that yeah
I thought he was sooo and like cuz he
was all in the speech like you couldn't
kill me or you minute I forgot the
speech it's kind of vague now but he was
like talking about how there's no way
anyone can kill he's all-powerful and
you'll never stop and that was so that
was so cool though in that moment cuz I
like how a toy it keeps that story going
like okay what is this exactly Return of
the Jedi can do you know it goes into
that fight that fight is another one of
the coolest things I've seen all of your
guards that was a great with the
auditorium there are cool ass shots in
that I love that shout when she passes
the lightsaber to kylo and then he just
Chu hear it turn on and they all had
like different kinds of weapons to find
lightsabers where that wanted to see a
variety of different martial arts with
weapons yeah and they provide that
they're in that fight and then working
together you're like okay I see where
it's going and I love how this dome had
like what an extra half hour 40 minutes
after that it could have probably ended
a few minutes later if they just made
kylo ago guys because they don't do that
you're still like oh my god I love how
not black and white this situation these
guys is fascinating thing about the
trailer is everyone was freaking out
about that one questions like Oh ray
gonna join kylo and it's like that is
kind of the question but not in that way
at all I joined the first order are they
both gonna kind of join each other on a
different level so you're sort of thing
like it's just moving to end with like
them doing their own thing now yeah and
then it confronts that again ya know
when he asks her to join him in ruling
the galaxy and I love that shot when
they don't say goodbye to each other or
whatever but but when they could see
each other oh and then she just has the
door go up and there's two things I want
to say about snow except one
I kind of viewed it as an alternative to
what would have happened had Anakin
Skywalker killed obi-wan Kenobi and
Revenge of the Sith and on Mustafar he
probably would have done that to the
emperor would have just killed him and
betrayed him and done something similar
today
and try to take over together so I kind
of looked at it as an alternate version
of what Anakin Skywalker would have done
this character does have a lot of
resemblance to Anakin Skywalker in terms
of he's conflicted with the force
obviously he's got family issues in
terms of you know conflict within him
but again just getting on the word
device if I have a real big feeling I
did appreciate the flipping it on its
head and not something I didn't expect
but I was just there was just it was an
incredible moment but again I have a
feeling a lot of people are not going to
like that you built up this character of
Supreme Leader Snoke and you know
there's a lot of interesting ways you
can go with this character in his
backstory how did he get so powerful and
oh it's NAB it just it's all to the
wayside he's dead he's gone it just kind
of feels like with the way it happens
and maybe I gotta watch it a few more
times but it just feels like it's like
not an important part of the storyline
just the way he's just like executed and
honestly I just haven't really even
cared about the whole I know people have
been theorizing who I know who that
house know is for so I've even watched
videos on it it was like looking forward
to it yeah absolutely I would love to
have known all that information at the
same time I was like I think it's clever
that this movie this franchise is not
really about that it's fair sometimes to
go ah that's not the point though yeah
yeah and I had that thought first was a
second in the movie theater I was like
wow cuz so many hours of fan theories
yeah Snoke is used in that moment you
see that Snoke being used right now as a
purpose to serve kylo story is it's not
like kylo secondary bad guy now and then
there's smoke it's like they're building
up our primary bad guy by the time we
get to part 3 which is kylo so I was
like that's even more clever and I think
more exciting because this film did it
it got me to love Kyla I didn't like
kylo in the first movie but in this
morning I was like dude I love this guy
yeah yeah how you're describing that is
it makes me feel a little bit better
from that but I still have a feeling
like people because they were theorizing
so many different things oh yeah that's
holy exist you're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna get a little
bit you know butter over the choice that
they made and make it feel like oh that
kind of wasn't that important or heat
the threat level wasn't as big with this
character just because of the way he
defeated so easily kind of the way it
seemed even though it was a sick-ass
trick that kylo ren pulled on him plus
now we've been robbed of another Andy
Serkis performance top notch effects on
him - oh yeah the way the character
visually looked I think maybe that was
one of my biggest you know things I was
upset with with Snoke and I know
everyone's gonna point out in the
comments well with Emperor Palpatine we
didn't get a lightsaber scene with him
so why are you pissed off about you know
Snoke a little more than with him and I
don't know it's just to get out there I
get and I get you know yeah we do get
and I I thought about this in the
theater and this is what reminded me of
like a lord of the Rings caliber movie
while I was watching this is like you
have that scene with him where it's
clear like he's run in the room she
tries to summon the lightsaber he's like
no I got that thing it brings it over
here and he didn't need to use the
lightsaber for me to get his power and I
like that they did that because as a
supreme leader of all that is malevolent
I feel like the this thing way to make
him scariest is by doing it without
showing him fight ok fine I'll concede
and I'll say I agree to that I think one
thing I would have been proud even
though I grew with every thing you said
I think things I would have appreciated
was you know maybe some scenes were him
and Kyla like he's maybe training him in
the dark in the the ways of the Sith and
seeing some of those scenes play out
because that was one thing I was looking
forward to after the force awakens where
he says to general Hux when Starkiller
base is being destroyed
bring me kylo Ren I must complete his
training and I was looking forward to
seeing sister on my TV show Andrew yes
already awakened at 1.5 it was already
known I get it this movie is a hundred
and fifty two minutes long which means
it's ten minutes longer than the last
longest film that's ever come out and
that was attack of the clones so there's
a lot going on in this film in there
were definitely some moments where you
know Snoke felt him like yeah where I
felt empowered by this character but
there were other things that again the
biggest best word I'm gonna use to
describe things that happen in this film
there's gonna be lots of divisive
feelings from fans and other people
towards what happens but as it should be
from your guys's perspective I love how
you're pointing out like I loved how
they kind of twisted and turned the
tables like this is yeah there are some
things like that
you'll recognize some Star Wars and then
we're gonna twist and turn it a little
bit into our own you know take them like
we feel like they're reminding us I like
know that the heart of this story is our
main characters and that's what
everything else is being used to serve
is the journey of these characters is
that's what we remember and by the time
this is all done you know we don't
really get to know the emperor except
for like the prequels but you know even
then you just go oh he just I get plot
stuff about him
I got ass though what happened when Luke
died I threw me off so he I guess he
just used up the amount of energy oh
yeah it was four she was four strained I
guess right they they didn't really go
home my lighter strands me every night
mmm I says my girlfriend force turns me
every night I figured this video oh yeah
why does more strain yeah threw me up
I'm like wait why exactly did he die
okay I mean I like that he died I
thought it was a good death a
well-earned death and I loved that his
art of believing in the Jedi and then
passing it on sir it ends in a way where
I'm like where he's even a million times
cooler now because I'll loose faith and
the reason he died was because he has
faith in Rey yeah we're saying earlier
in the film I mean he was saying that he
did want to die had nothing else to live
for and you know it feels like he he'd
squandered and failed yeah obviously was
what happened with better kylo Ren Ben
solo and I guess like Natalie Portman's
character she died of heartbreak so I
don't know if you die in these movies I
mean again you used up the foot he
hadn't used the force in years so maybe
that had something to do with it yes
he would have I feel like that's one of
those mystical things where it's just
like he disappeared he rejoined the
force well I mean you I mean obviously
we saw that Yoda was at a very old age
so that's why he died Yoda appearance
you know I love my Yoda Cameo he served
a purpose he served a purpose and he was
ready and they even expanded what the
force means in that moment that it's not
about rules and religion and all these
things it's not about like Yoda burns it
about that man I love that book
which helps a lot with some people get
up in arms about you know I was raised
so good at the force you know she hasn't
had all the training the proper form
because if she's getting into priesthood
and maybe there's still an argument to
be made about that at the same time that
all that stuff with Yoda really made me
go see it's not a it's really just about
who you are as a human being in your
natural state of faith or whatever so
practical yeah but again I just I love
that that that seemed I love how they
touched back to the humor on the scenes
of Dagobah with Luke and you're like I'm
not gonna say a recreation but just the
recreation of the the awesome feeling we
had whenever we see these characters
interact with each other in Empire
Strikes Back it wasn't just like the the
moment that made you feel like you know
nostalgic but was just it was actually a
very purpose building moment for Luke on
where he needed to go as a character and
I appreciated his mentor again except to
become a good mentor he needed his
mentor that obi-wan was gonna come damn
you Luke Rey's parents that's gonna fit
is that something that's something that
product pissed some people off - but I'm
like it's not about fine it's not about
the questions it's about the journey and
the growth of these characters they're
making it way less about or where is
parents who's a supreme leader snoke you
know all these questions that people
keep an theorizing on I feel like the
filmmakers think this is a lot more
people than just Ryan Johnson's decision
like yes this is made in Brian Johnson
style but there's a lot more people on
board with how this story is being
crafted right now you know so the
decision to just go I think it would be
more power
for a if she like you know if her
parents were just nobodies they're not
this special thing she doesn't come from
a special lineage now making it even
more compelling already man for her to
be with kylo now it's even stronger
journey for when she becomes the
ultimate Jedi in part three if it goes
that path and is actually at the poem
like we'll look it with that path yeah
yeah it kind of lowers the universe in
terms of like oh so everyone has to be a
Skywalker or like connected to them or
something like yeah but it was
interesting to know it could be just a
random anybody said they well they I
felt like they ended the Skywalker
storyline with this one because carrie
fisher's passed away Luke Skywalker is
now dead I did like how though they had
that beautiful moment at the end with
that kid were like you feel like Luke
back with that space kid and like who
just wants to go on some journeys and
you know get in some trouble do that
thought of hope and having that with
that kid and just that moment like I
felt like that was I felt like that was
Luke again there from a new hope in
terms of you know we started off on such
a young journey with that kid in that
moment I was a very nice way to end the
film via humor which no one was speaking
of in storyline I didn't really care for
in the first half of his storyline it
did start feeling it's sort of feeling
like he don't really know what to do
with Finn's storyline but they gave him
a really interesting companion who I
really love rose I thought her character
was great she was funny she was sweet
and Deering braved she had a presence to
this movie her interaction with Finn is
like a tenderness about yeah good you
know cuz do you meet her when she's just
lost her sister but she's also like
really invigorated for the cause because
she lost her sister yeah and her her
teaming up with Fannin's doing this
mission together what was that planet
they go to can't tow bike I love the way
they handled a little gore isn't you
know just the gambling style yeah well
what I was thinking about was even when
she's like the worst place I've ever
been to and then it cuts to it you're
like oh it's just something like lavish
place it's just booze yeah it's Vegas
for a planet seeing all the creature
designs is fantastic and seeing the kind
of the rich I always feel like you go to
like poor places and star wars yeah rich
folks do debauchery and stuff live well
yeah I love that I love that they took
the time to touch I'm like who do you
think can afford to live here
yeah like the people supplying all the
weapons for the star war
yeah like of a they went into different
things like who sells the weapons the
the starships the blasters I also like
to and we talked about earlier with hold
o and Po I like seeing the rift in the
resistance like how it's not a little
just cookie cutter yeah let's go beat
the bad guys that's it there's actually
conflict in there they all have the same
goals but they have different ways of
trying to achieve it and I appreciate it
seeing that conflict in the group Emily
oh so there are problems so it does feel
more grounded it's not you know what I
mean it's not just a movie where you
know things get resolved so easily yeah
there is a rift and there are problems
you know within the resistance I like
seeing that I think road one helps set
up a tone for this in a certain way
because one thing I said about road one
was how I felt like in the word Star
Wars it has that really has the war vibe
I felt like this had it too and a lot
more of the strategic vibe like I like
the whole Master and Commander thing
going on with the first order ship just
shooting at them for a long-ass time
until their damn shields go down they
can destroy them and I'm trying to
figure out a way to escape as they know
they're outnumbered it was done more
than war way of strategy instead of just
the way the battles were done the add-on
sequences I ship rose and Finn I prefer
I prefer it over Finn and right yeah I
think I mean again a lot of people are
probably not gonna agree with us but I
think the reason I like them so much is
just cuz how much they have in common
yeah and you know like the ones in
sanitation ones you know I wish she
enchanted well she had to watch the
escape pod so there's like personalities
yeah they just mentioned well better
together and they have a really good
chemistry with each other and the way
they interact with each other like
they're really good - yeah they're like
I could definitely see these two
together and obviously you know we get
that moment in the end where she saves
him - like I really thought in the
moment like he was actually gonna die
there I thought they were gonna kill off
it yeah heard the ex mother Rose ex
machina where she just comes in to save
it was just so satisfying and so sweet
like the way they're just progressing
those twos relationship like I really
appreciate it and then when we see ray
like look jealous when she sees that
yeah I'm like oh
and another thing that this struck me
about Finn's storylines specifically
Finn and Rosa's storyline you know I was
sharing some of that feeling of it seems
like this is kind of at a different pace
than the rest of the story it seems like
a side adventure for part of it and then
by the end of it I thought that that
kind of also went to show like this is a
very this is a very familiar plan we're
gonna sneak in and mess something up and
that's gonna be the key to us winning
and it doesn't work of all the plot
lines that was the one that felt the
most like it could have been rehashed
but the way it turns out it's not or at
least nothing ever goes according of
that I mean even they recruit Benicio
del Toro's DJ by the way is teaching
great yeah I really felt like it was a
cool Benicio del Toro that a performance
you know like yeah nice to the tour I
love to see at the same time he fits so
well into the world and I love this kind
of like thief / coder who never really
seen that I mean I could be run just
thinking about I can't really think of
too many times where we've seen like a
hacker type of character like it's so
seeing new types of characters like into
this universe it was cool like it just
felt more grounded and he adds to that
that gray conversation because he has
that moment with Finn he shows Finn that
like you know the resistance by is the
örebro despise and weapons to you know
everybody got guns man yeah I just like
he's on the in-between of all there's
like isn't happy side he's a survivor I
mean even though people are gonna hate
him because what he does even though it
was more survival in the moment you
dealt was yeah but also he does have
some good moments where he gives back
them and down the road that was a really
good moment for me character was and
he's got some cool like cryptic lines
yeah not definitely a fun fact about
Benicio del Toro he was actually cast as
Darth Maul and a little film called Star
Wars Episode one The Phantom Menace but
when George Lucas changed many of the
lines or rather you know erased all of
Darth Maul's lines because he has like
two lines in the whole movie but he said
those I was like I'm out he got to be in
a Star Wars Rey Park
it makes me respect Finn's storyline a
little bit more because when I think
about in retrospect Finn really screwed
over the resistance the whole time this
plan was not something ran by ready to
get back to Ray you know he wanted to
get back to Ray he's also trying to help
with the whole ship problem so they were
looking for the for the
powder but because they brought the
coder by the coder was able the coder
betrays them and then they just able to
really start taking down the ships at
that point then when they're escaping
and everything he really contributed to
making making this worse for them him
willing to sacrifice himself like
feeling like no he has to I it made me
appreciate that sort of form of him
making mistakes like he's really
learning here yeah it was for him to
learn and also I mean he gets to square
off with phasma finally and phasma was
one of the bummer things about this
movie to me because I I like Gwendoline
Christie a lot and I think that
character looks and sounds awesome in
theory for him to get to square off with
her was cool my question is this as I
thought about that as like the phasma
scene served a purpose for Finn yeah so
that's what I mean it's it's less about
like who the hell's Captain phasma so I
started wondering would I be upset about
this if it wasn't Gwendolyn creased
Christie like if it was just someone
under the masts and they didn't like
promote this character and it was just
in the force awakens at one point and
then in this move and they didn't like
heavily promote this character would it
still upset me I don't think it would
let me answer that question for you I
don't know anything about Gwendoline
Christie before I saw Star Wars The
Force awakens and it upset me really
yeah big time but is it because they
promoted Captain phasma I mean
definitely a little promoted but again
just it's the payoff the satisfaction
with a threat level I just never got the
vibe in both films like I just felt like
the character was very weak in terms of
the gave up very early let the shield's
down and the force awakens and in this
film one fight scene and she was
defeated pretty easily by Finn and I
know Finn's a competent warrior but
she's Captain phasma like she's she was
in charge of him and I'm not saying that
she needs to win the battle but the
battle needs to be tough and hard so
that when thin does Wentz like damn how
did he beat her that the the stakes it
felt impossible in the moment I never
got the sense of the feeling phasma was
well yeah right I do feel like if I
didn't know what was going on Kristi I
would be maybe just less upset but still
a little upset because you got to assume
that that her character has a status
that she must have earned like she's got
to be the brewery end of the storm truth
yeah she's gotta be that good yeah did
you only start trooper with a female
boys and they'd do a role out on that
character they were like check out the
new stuff for the new Star Wars I would
be bust one thing I will say it
love what they did what the character
was her armor when they were choosing
blasters and it was just like yeah that
was a cool touch use that more to your
advantage make her seem more impossible
to defeat like stuff like that or have
her like beat up a couple of soldiers on
the resistance side yeah do something to
where we're like how is Finn supposed to
beat her and then when finally Finn does
beat her it's like that was a satisfying
moment I was wasted I just thought it
was a wasted character as well the
character it's so much more potential
than what we got and in the grand scheme
of things phasma doesn't really affect
much of the other characters - exactly
that's what I mean so it's like in one
way it is looking at that but I feel
like no matter what at this point
oh the use of bb-8 was you got to do
some cool stuff when he shows up and
takes over that one yeah yeah that was a
badass yeah he is a character is it
actual like got a personality a
character and also I love that moment
when r2 and Luke reunite yeah yeah and
even also Chewie and Luke when they
reunite and it's interesting to how you
just mentioned about the way they used
to be be aiding his personality it's
almost like bb-8 and I know Kate was
rogue when this was beyond a long time
ago but I feel like BBN k2s oh are
almost like taking over for a c3 pio and
r2d2 where they're our favorite droids
in our hearts yeah even though Kate to
us so obviously it's gone the way
they're using these new droids no this
times I just I really love it and it's
just inventive I know I'm interested
nobody gets to wear a costume in this
movie that was really cool that was
freaking off I'd like r2d2 and Threepio
but I feel like one of the best things
that the new Star Wars films have done
in terms of taking advantage of updated
effects is enhance the personalities of
the droids oh and I think bb-8 and k2s
oh are great examples of that honestly
hey I'm down for Threepio I'm down for
some r2d2 but I'm a little bit more
drawn to like K to s7 yeah but still you
do appreciate those moments like we're
poe is like cutting off c-3po also - I
really love the moment of Luke Skywalker
with c-3po and he gives him the wink as
Luke is honestly the only one who's ever
been nice to see three feel and actually
treats him like he's a human even though
he is a cyborg but that was one of my
favorite moments in the entire film Luke
just giving him that I we were some of
your favorites ploy their moments of
this movie put it in the comments below
because we love spoilers subscribe to
the real rejects don't ever get me a
spoiler I hope that notification belt
follow us on social media but beyond
anything else we do I want you to follow
us on patreon.com slash the real rejects
has become like a second YouTube channel
for us and download and follow us on the
star what's that nothing else to promote
except for our instagrams really growing
right now I hope you guys follow us over
there I actually put out a tweet
recently got a hundred something and
retweets it was really good 130
Instagram yeah twitter twitter but more
importantly follow andrew in the valley
because he is a man who likes to drive
it isn't finished movie man to infinity
and beyond take care see you on YouTube
one of these days